oh definitely use it
[Music]
Clayton steel Anna guarantee
Carrie Beckerman and from Dallas Texas
I'm from Florida originally in Laguna
Beach
so we're going to start up my creative
agency called Ellen digital fiber is the
name of the company I think it will
smell like beer yeah I think it will
smell like an old theater maybe a little
moldy but not terrible mix of Bo and
really strong of you I'm Katie nice now
is take her off for being head matter is
the last DC nice that that's just me
actually that was a huge to be that we
had and I'm we realize that very thank
you okay definitely thought about that I
really thought about where to say health
is like I'll make love to you that one
yes I was like blaring on my way over
here the red line god of wine problems
you might go to I'm just like I'm just
turning into a bro you're like being
back because um very very thick as their
sweet and delicious and really bad for
you that sounds like my dating life I
got married 20 bunches of those because
uh I'm crunchy and sweet frosted
mini-wheats
there's like you like to think you're
helping yes we do
so it's a little bit of both
[Music]